hello and welcome to this video playing
not Lausen and this is an important game
because if I lose this okay yeah if I
lose this then I'm going to be down to
below 2,200 yeah this is an interesting
funny line h5 is just a bad move but
people rarely plain idea 3 which is
given by the very nice position I mean
the way i'm currently playing that might
still lose this but wow but it's it's
pretty awful this stuff would like okay
so what is he doing here a g5 yeah i
should have just gone to g2 actually it
would have been a bit easier I'm sorry
for the noise ah so what to do here I
should just go to g2 I'm just plain
stupid moves all the way and now this
actually makes some senses idiotic stuff
with age 5 just due to g2 immediately
anyway
maybe I'm so still okay I mean this is
just completely unplayable the position
here with age five and then in San g5
yeah [ __ ] yeah again let's see let's
first see if I can still do something
here it still looks pretty terrible for
black
it's just a developing
maybe just developing small enough
that's possible I mean its position is
enormously weekend but I have some cons
a congestion in my position here yeah
we'll see probably what is he going to
Joe just Knight f6 year I should have
gone to g5 instead of f4 ok anyway he
still has problems even though I played
the the bed night at five giving him all
those camping
if we should create some wow maybe even
I can go a three year okay III kind of
irritated me still does
okay so what is strange position
sure
angle Castle mom somehow i also would
just would like to attack this this pawn
here but drilling gap between us S III
and this is just does not work not not
well at least and pawn to e3 is
irritating me to no end
I cannot cancel short i wonder if you
three is amor but it looks extremely
slow okay
try to Castle know myself like the
weaknesses on d3 and f3 and so on with
naming it doesn't have a clear way to
exploit that yeah I wanted to play pawn
Teague's but then he can take g5 and
give a check on edge for which is
annoying damn it this is not what I
wanted to do
an ID format before stuff okay just play
the normal move let's say yeah but is
that such a big deal i mean i can kick
it away
when a sin was hanging right
please don't tell me that there's some
way for him to not lose now I really
should win now come on I don't don't see
how he saves this check first
black versa yeah I'm happy that I want
this I mean this is just a completely
unsound opening h5 is just as bad but
people don't refute it off marine they
play h4n 790 of three years of using h5
very clearly is you 49 h 4 and this is
just good for white and and lysis a bit
for that video series that i mentioned
earlier which is 24 and I mean black is
in bad shape now because this pawn is
just exposed and age five is just
weakening his position the night has an
easy route back and I just made a big
mistake by like back g5 he's nuts i
played nine and five and of course he
goes d5 I just have to go to g2 and this
is essentially over now because he
cannot hold all those weaknesses is just
unplayable position black essentially i
get the game without the pawn being on
d4 so people almost certainly lose that
you fall upon him it's very difficult
for him to not lose it note that i'm
always getting additional tempe you like
here sorry too many arrows you know like
this attacking the porn at age four it
just just a terrible position for black
yeah unfortunately I played 95 and now
things yeah turning around you you just
got those two moves for free and now he
is better yeah but i think it probably
should just just play it takes here
threatening this and this is very
annoying now this is very bad for one a
kg for d3 and this now is just
completely completely bonkers I was
always afraid of III but he never played
it this one I have to do this stuff
and I mean it wasn't clear to me but it
looked very terrifying the engine thinks
this is roughly equal i mean but i don't
know i don't like it yeah this was a
move I really wasn't sure about that I
couldn't really find something good
maybe queen bee three and then long
castles is what the engine suggests yeah
this is better this is good now cheeks
and now long castles and black is better
and my position is just not about
coordinated especially my king this week
doesn't seem to be totally clear i come
to the end but it just isn't any good I
mean he I'm okay and I'm definitely okay
after and after after this knight Knight
f3 is losing straight away he has to
take yet and play this I think I'm good
now yeah I mean I'm a pawn up for
whatever this point is worth but I still
have a pawn up Jim and this was losing
straight Elena yeah that's very silly i
just i mean i kind of you kind of think
okay my opponent is a maniac so play
quickly and sorry this is just New York
move just going back and black is pretty
much busted already okay well thanks for
watching